xavier bertrand qui arrive largement en
tête au premier tour dans les hauts de
france le rassemblement national est
distancé la république en marche
éliminé xavier bertrand qui se félicite
d'avoir je cite briser les mâchoires du
rassemblement national et qui a ajouté
par ailleurs qu'il a fait du front
national mon unique et demi je cite
parmi les autres résultats qu'on peut
évoquer vincent hervé morin candidat ait
l'air arrive en tête au premier tour en
normandie devant le rassemblement
national et le son candidat nicolas bay
et devant le ps et europe ecologie les
verts le sortant alain rousset du ps
largement en tête en nouvelle aquitaine
toujours selon les premières estimations
il est dernière renaud muselier
candidats la république les républicains
modem est au coude à coude avec le
rassemblement national thierry mariani
en paca mais il y donnait en tête le
président ait l'air sortant renaud
muselier est en effet bénéficie en effet
du soutien de la république en marche et
des centristes du modem et de l'udps et
y est ils seraient en tête en paca avec
34 5% des voix contre 33% pour le
rassemblement national thierry mariani
selon les premières estimations ce que
je vous donne
pardon pour le rassemblement national et
son candidat thierry mariani et les
informations que vous donne sont celles
des premières estimations de l'ifop pour
le figaro centre val de loire le sortant
ps françois bonneau devance de quatre
points le candidat aleksandar nikolic du
rassemblement national
la sortante ps marie-guite dufay de
vence le rn julien odoul en bourgogne
franche côté il ya un duel serré encore
centre gilles simeoni et autonomistes et
laurent marc angeli dlr laurent viaud
wauquiez qu'on a pu entendre il ya
quelques minutes vers 20h15 arrive
largement en tête au premier tour avec
près de 47% en auvergne rhône-alpes et
le sortant ps loïc chez des gir arrive
en tête en bretagne devant la république
en marche
christelle morançais lr devance
largement matthieu orphelin des verts et
jean paul garraud du ps pcf dans les
pays-de-la-loire et enfin gens
retenaient
dlr arriverait largement arrivant
largement en tête dans le grand est
devant les candidats laurent jacobellis
du r n quel